en France il y a eu des manifestations de jaune
gilets en Allemagne étaient des manifestations
contre les limites de la visibilité physique
l'infection, comme dans un certain nombre d'autres pays
y compris en Pologne contre l'interdiction
les avortements étaient des manifestations ils ont été dispersés
vous savez très très dur dispersé et
c'est si je me souviens bien sur jaune
s'investit des militants français des droits de l'homme
parce que les structures internationales dans ce
y compris le Bureau du Commissaire des Nations Unies aux droits
les chats étaient silencieux et ils ont répondu diffusés
la situation avec les gilets jaunes n'est pas du tout comme ça
comment ils couvrent la situation disons dans
Russie ou Biélorussie et uniquement sur
l'étape initiale si prudemment invitée
pour surmonter les différences, mais alors quand
gilets jaunes
a commencé à faire face très cruel
réponse brutale de la police lorsque
selon les militants français des droits de l'homme
près de 15 000 balles en caoutchouc ont été tirées
selon les manifestants, 1 000 personnes étaient
12 000 ont été blessés, deux d'entre eux ont été arrêtés
des milliers ont été condamnés, y compris à
peine de prison réelle
la moitié de ces deux mille à ce sujet
personne ne dit que c'est considéré comme ok
choses parce qu'il y a